non pas de foot pas de faute sur la rue
tranquille et à la maison mais avec qui
avec Fatou
vous avez l'air des prix
non c'était très sympa et pas de faute
voilà j'étais très content la maison
tous les deux on parle pendant des
heures tu fais que parler
qu'est-ce qu'elle a dit bah elle rien
mais moi je parle
[Rires]
tiens Delphine alors moi puisque j'avais
pas de Valentin hier soir bah du coup
j'ai accepté l'invitation de quelqu'un
d'un ami qui m'invite à dîner
vu que tout le monde dit que c'est un
jour comme les autres ben j'en ai fait
un jour comme les autres et j'ai accepté
l'invitation d'un ami il a rien
d'essayer non même pas une petite un
petit
snacké
est-ce que lui il veut te pécho c'est ça
la question
il a eu des attentions particulières un
petit bouquet de fleurs
un mec qui t'invite pour la
Saint-Valentin
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
et juste
les jeans larges comme ça c'est pas fait
depuis 86
[Rires]
et les femmes qui ont pas pu fêter la
Saint-Valentin à cause du match d'hier
il aurait pu accepter aussi l'invitation
d'amis pour aller manger
Guillaume tu peux l'expliquer évidemment
est-ce que est-ce qu'il t'a invité
est-ce qu'il a payé l'addition alors oui
oui
ça n'a rien à voir est-ce que pendant le
dîner il a eu des des questionnements
tu en es où de te menstruation
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
non mais il est trop jeune pour moi de
toute façon
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
tu as pas proposé
avec un ami puisque c'est un amour
ça ça compte aussi parce que ça c'est
l'autre genre de mec bah ça devient
compliqué là
les mecs qui sont en couple et qui
disent que la femme enceinte n'a pas de
valeur et puis il y a ceux qui sont pas
en couple qui disent que ceux qui sont
en couple qui ont assez des barres de
fer c'est tout
c'est qu'ils veulent pas lâcher
d'oseille il veut pas te raconter
l'histoire les mecs qui sont en couple
et qui disent à Saint-Valentin ça sert à
rien c'est juste des mecs c'est des bars
voilà c'est tout voilà alors il y a pas
Mathieu Delormeau ici mais ça aurait été
un bon exemple voilà je vous le dis
voilà voilà on va pas on va pas se
raconter l'histoire comment ça va toi
j'étais au restaurant hier soir avec une
copine c'est toi
[Applaudissements]
Saint-Valentin
ça coûtait très cher trop cher et c'est
normal quand tu as quatre ou cinq
Valentine
tu vois lui c'est un truc de fou je
faisais qu'est-ce que tu faisais de de
fou avant ouais alors avant j'adorais
louer un une très grande suite d'hôtel
dans un très grand voilà très beau
Palace et en fait c'était voilà c'était
pas très utile parce que parfois il peut
pas sérieux
en plus ouais excuse-moi
on sait sur Europe 1 il y a Hondelatte
raconte
l'émission elle dure 15 secondes
Jacques Mesrine était un malfrat à
demain
pas possible tu m'as foutu un rock
pareil non mais sans déconner non mais
qu'est-ce que tu as fait hier avec ta
femme ah non j'étais au restaurant avec
ta femme bien sûr tu fais avec tous les
enfants qui font comme ça dans la nature
de deux ans à 27 ans et comment tu fais
pour payer
alors tu sais quoi c'est ma femme qui
m'invite non c'est vrai
[Musique]
justement
quand j'avais 20 ans j'avais une carte
comme ça je n'ai jamais pu en avoir une
ben maintenant j'ai une carte voilà tu
peux même pas dépenser rien voilà
[Rires]
donc hier tu étais où et au restaurant
japonais d'accord et tu as pris quoi de
la fondue
il y avait un menu Saint-Valentin ah ça
m'énerve
le menu c'est le meilleur moyen de se
faire entrer et on t'impose tout non
mais c'est ça
la dernière fois mais mon du menu
Saint-Valentin
et voilà et ramène-nous ce que tu as de
moins cher
non mais tu vois moi je suis une barre
de fer mais non non
[Rires]
est-ce que tu veux manger avant
après comme vous parce que tu pourrais
avoir une petite fringale
non non tu préfères tu préfères manger
avant après
on sait jamais ce qui peut arriver dans
la vie fais-le au plus vite parce que
non mais je te le dis non mais c'est
vrai on est obligé d'attendre le 8 mars
ça fait tellement longtemps sur la tête
de ma mère il y a des chauves-souris qui
vont pas faire ça
c'est un Harry Potter le bac
qui sort
ah non mais sérieux je suis sûr je suis
sûr ah c'est sûr et certain